GOVERNMENT, CONTINUING
RESOLUTION, TONIGHT.
FINALLY, TONIGHT, NOTABLE
QUOTABLES.
>> STRAIGHT TO THE FOX NEWS
ALERT, ROGER STONE IS INDIELTED
BY A GRAND JURY.
[CHANTING]
>> FEDERAL WORKERS GOING TO
HOMELESS SHELTERS.
>> I KNOW THEY ARE, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY.
[CHANTING]
>> LET THEM EAT CAKE KIND OF
ATTITUDE?
>> I'M GETTING HUNDREDS AND
REPORTS I CAN'T COME TO WORK ANY
MORE.
>> I'M RUNNING FOR.
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> BUZZFEED GOT IT WRONG.
>> WE EXPECT THE UNITED KINGDOM
TO TELL US WHAT THEY WANT, WHAT
THEY REALLY, REALLY WANT.
>> CAN YOU TRY TO TEACH A GOEPT
HOW TO CLIMB A TREE BUT YOU'RE
BETTER OFF HIRING A SQUIRREL IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
>> TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
>> HE DIDN'T HAVE A MAGA HAT,
THAT WAS NOT A PRO-LIVE PROTEST,
THIS WOULDN'T BE A STORY.
>> LOW POINT IN HISTORY, THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE TO UNINVITE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> WE NEED A PHYSICAL BARRIER
YOU CAN'T CRAWL UNDER, CLIMB
OVER, DRIVE THROUGH, OR WALK
AROUND.
>> NICHOLAS MA DUR OWE IS A
DICTATOR WITH NO LEGITIMATE
CLAIM TO POWER.
>> THAT'S WHAT SOCIALISM GETS
YOU.
>> HOW MANY (BLEEP) DO YOU GIVE.
>> ZERO.
>> WE HAVE REACHED A DEAL TO END
THE SHUTDOWN AND REOPEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.